c'est risqué puisqu'il vient de choisir
appalaches steven est débarqué à
montréal avec son chien il y a quelques
semaines il campe derrière l'ancien
terminus
c'est la dernière station de sa chute
accélérée par la pandémie
la vie est compliquée je travaille je
n'arrive pas à me loger je n'ai pas de
jeu pas d'argent il rejoint dans la rue
des gens comme denis qui est sans
domicile fixe depuis des années les gens
très peu de monnaie les gens tiennent
plurielle et j'assume je pose ne nous
ont pas comme ça c'est une cabine de
l'hôtel et avec la fermeture des
commerces même l'accès aux toilettes est
plus difficile que jamais
l'itinérance est plus dure qu'avant la
pandémie et touche aussi plus de gens qu
auparavant
québec ajoute donc 700 lits d'urgence de
plus que l'an dernier
ces 700 lits de plus 1650 au total dans
le 380 qui va être à l'automne cet hôtel
c'est place dupuis au centre-ville de
montréal qui devient un refuge de 380
places avec des étages réservés aux
femmes itinérantes qui malheureusement
sont de plus en plus nombreuses pour les
femmes en fête ses 90 nouvelles places
non mix qui s'ajoutent aux places
actuelles montréal souhaite que ces
nouvelles places dans les refuges et 6
de ceux qui campent rue notre dame à
partir la mairesse ne veut pas les
évincés de force avec la force
on va pas l'idée n'est pas de rendre les
gens encore plus vénérables ils font les
années dans les ressources oui mais bien
des itinérants n'ont pas du tout
l'intention d'utiliser les nouvelles
places en refuge
non j'ai bonne solution si je sais juste
met en place il souhaite plutôt avoir
accès à un logement abordable attendra
le lendemain matin mois d'août ou aux
mouches travail cisjordanie autonomes
québec et montréal affirme travailler
sur un plan pour accroître l'offre de
logement pour les plus vulnérables
ici david gêne-t-il et radio-canada
montvert